hello only francs and welcome to
London's Leicester Square we're here for
the European premiere of suicide squads
the latest installment in DC's extended
universe
the stars are on their way Will Smith
Margot Robbie jared leto Joel Kinnaman
and of course our very own Cara
Delevingne
but first let's take a look why it feels
so good to be bad I want to build a team
of some very bad people who I think can
do some good yeah Joker's must be crazy
assemble a team of the world's most
dangerous super villains provide them
with the most powerful Arsenal at the
government's disposal and send them off
to defeat an insuperable enigmatic enemy
what could possibly go wrong what
arrived it's about this sort of insane
family of bad guys that comes together
to do some amazing things and there are
bad guys but they do have good hearts
and each character really has a spark
and a life to them I've never played a
baddie before you know it's really
liberating and fun as an actor it's fun
to ad-lib than to create and to say and
do things that are so in opposition to
who you really are this is a character
with no rules you know I think fun is
one of the crucial ingredients to the
Joker a little bit of chaos and there's
a little method to the madness or
madness for the method I guess I can't
wait to show you my toys the whole idea
of the bad versus evil not good versus
evil the the characters are fantastic
and and everybody that was in the film
had a 100% commitment to doing it and
director David Ayer that's just a
phenomenal director it was amazing
everything sustained it was not sick as
incredible an amazing experience you
have to buckle in as soon as the music
starts pretty much a rollercoaster for
the next two hours the movie is it's a
fun ride you know more than anything
it's a fun ride let's play
got some better answer I love iMac love
iMac you go to see a movie to forget
about everything else and there's no
theater that you do that more and then
the anorexic color is the cinematography
the wardrobe the costume all the visual
effects it's going to look amazing it's
gonna look amazing
chills up your spine I love it there's
so much detail and it's so rich and such
a dense frame that you really see
everything in this movie the bigger the
screen the better it really feels like
you're in the space when it's that big
you know when it sort of engulfs you I
love I love it just kind of takes it to
the next level
don't forget we're the bad guys Suicide
Squad is one of the summer's biggest
blockbusters so there's only really one
way to experience it and that's in IMAX
what you're gonna do you wanna see some
oh yeah once they stop yes I want to see
stop I was just trying to get you there
know our feelings all right we good